we're going to show another reaction now
that is again started by water but this
reaction is actually really impressive
it's by foreign what is that it's the
one reaction I've seen that's made me
completely speechless
Neal's got his lifelong favorite
chemical potassium if you remember the
potassium video from our periodic table
of videos that you know there were kind
of reaction that you get with potassium
when it hits water we are going to
introduce tests into water again but
we're going to introduce also another
ingredient and that's dry diethyl ether
so until my time here I've never seen
touch iam cut up so I never realized
just how nice it looks on the inside
before it tarnishes eels just mopping
off the excess oil and it's going to go
into that large beaker looking because
now in the fume cupboard and we're gonna
introduce some very dry diethyl ether it
has to be dry because if I pour this in
and it's just regular Daesan ether the
whole lot will go up and I don't want
that to happen so
that's that in potassium dried ice
Oliver our friend water here and watch
what happens
we've got ourselves some firewater
and the line look flames you see there
are due to the potassium so every soften
it's going out and it's reeling the
sparks are from the potassium itself
reacting with water actually ignite the
ether flames and that's why you're
getting those orange and purple flames
so you saw their reaction learners pour
water and the result was really obvious
you had the potassium burning in there
which is what gave the purple color of
the flames and now the reaction stop
because all the ethers been burnt off so
we'll approach of caution that the
beakers red hot now so we're gonna let
cool down hopefully there's no residual
potassium in there but I'll let Neal
find that out